okay so in this trail he's in a horse
stay still and i want him in a horse
because
uh it's very easy to uh push his weight
his line of gravity outside his base of
support
okay so in this drill what i'm looking
for
is that my technique is actually
attacking his center
and you'll be able to see that more
noticeably
okay so of course this part
is embryonic but i'm working on that
part
meaning yes i'm kind of stopping here
this is not the correct timing of making
a touch
okay but what i don't want to see is
this
it goes into a center
okay it doesn't have to do anything
[Music]
okay this one's a little tough
i can't go here and then try to turn it
it won't work but i'm also not just
spinning it while i'm over here
and there's no touch so
boom boom
one
okay let's okay so uh
you're in this stance so that you could
test that you actually have the
proper uh height
with depth check okay so if i if i'm
going here
and yes that's a touch on the balkan
but not on his body okay so
what i'm doing i'm going to go slow and
you'll see there's
energy that's going to go this way
and so he if he is tasked with the horse
stance
he'll lose his balance so it's not
enough to make him
just drop his arm do you see
you want you're looking for the line of
gravity
that goes into his base okay
then we have it a little tougher
on this one okay but it's still the same
i'm not doing this okay let's go